[Music]
[Applause]
you got basketball coming up tonight
hawks at the cavs pelicans at the
clippers as we bring in the commissioner
the nba adam silver commissioner how are
you this morning
hey dan i'm great how are you what game
are you going to tonight
just watching on tv tonight
i was wondering if
how where you went to school how that
affected you as far as wanting to do
this job or being involved in the nba
because you go to duke and then the
university of chicago
duke in the early 80s and then chicago
university of chicago when michael
jordan gets to town how much of an
impact did that have on you wanting to
do this
such an interesting question
duke had a huge impact on me wanting to
do this i'd say when i
went down to duke i grew up in
new york i was a knicks fan growing up
but i wasn't a huge college basketball
fan and then when i got to duke it was
coach k's first year
in 1980 and
at least then i mean the good the good
and bad news was the teams weren't great
you didn't have to sleep outside and
paint your face to go to a game so
um it suited me well but i really fell
in love with the program there and then
you're exactly right then i went to
university of chicago law school michael
had come a few years earlier i think i i
got there
in 85 so right around the same time
michael came and again same thing you
know
michael was a phenom but they weren't
winning in those early years you could
just go to the old bull stadium
you know 10 minutes before the game buy
a ticket and go so used to go with my
law school friends and so and that i
remember early days there the bulls you
thought you were experiencing something
pre-internet everything else that no one
else sort of understood like you felt
like you were in this special club um
watching michael jordan in those teams
so
you know and even then i'll say though
when i then finished law school
worked for a judge worked at a law firm
in new york it never occurred to me that
i'd have a career in sports
but then you went to nba entertainment
i so what happened was i um
i've been practicing law for a couple of
years and david stern had worked at the
same law firm my father had worked at i
didn't know him and i wrote him a letter
not thinking i would work at the nba but
asking for advice on how to transition
from being a lawyer into doing something
else i was actually most interested in
media
i one of the clients
of our law firm was hbo and i was
spending a lot of time working on media
cases and david ended up meeting with me
i s you know pre pre email old-fashioned
letter saying dear commissioner stern i
ended up meeting with him a month or so
later he gave me some advice and then
several months after that
his assistant called me and he said and
said
if you have time he'd like to see you
i've said of course and
i didn't understand what we were
he had in mind when we first met but as
it turned out he wanted to hire an
assistant so that was my first job as
the special assistant to the
commissioner and that was 1992.
how how many days in before he yelled at
you
half half a day
i was there
at one time he wanted to meet
and he was in another
part of his office
and i heard him yelling like at the top
of his lungs and i'm sitting there
and i'm going oh my god i'm in trouble
he came out and he would go
those bleeping contractors he goes i'm
trying to get work done at my house he
goes hey patrick how are you i'm going
oh my god like he
just snapped right into just being a
normal regular guy
no one was immune
i think he would have
made it about 15 minutes with a modern
hr department
these days
but but
he was he was equal opportunity whether
it was his contractor or an mba owner um
that's who he was i mean he brought a
lot of passion everything i i miss him
every day
but um
it it was a different time you know and
then ceos commissioners
um
i mean it
it was a full frontal assault being
yelled at by david literally like not
physically he wasn't that big a guy but
he was broad shouldered and it would
knock you back when he would yell
were you involved in the last dance the
jordan documentary i was very involved
in fact um i was the president of nba
entertainment um during michael's last
season on the bulls
when we went to
first jerry reinsdorf and then phil
jackson to get permission to do that and
then
i was the one sent to convince michael
um
what our what our agreement was at the
time and we knew each other well because
i was head of nba entertainment
was let's
on a handshake agree to allow us to be a
fly on the wall
and
i'll commit to you that this footage in
those days it was film and you know nba
entertainment out in secaucus we'll
we'll physically keep it in a different
place in our library and we'll never use
it unless we jointly agree we can do
something with it and so
we and then of course then he retired um
he came back at one point um we had
many conversations over the years um
with different potential directors and
he never quite warmed up to making it
and then
you know whenever that was five years
ago or so that
some of his
long time colleagues curtis polk sd
portnoy others
went to him and said it's time
there's a there's a generation out there
who
understand you as a brand and you have
shoes and you know jordan brand and all
that but but never understood who you
were and and
what you brought to the game and i and i
think that moved him and ultimately we
went out hire new director it was sort
of joint production um with with a group
and
obviously then espn uh in the middle of
the
you know pandemic you know accelerated
it recognized there was an opportunity
then it went to netflix but um you know
it
it was a fascinating process over many
years to make that documentary and by
the way dan when we made it there was
no one had suggested a documentary back
then or or
presentation was more than two hours
you know it's unheard right you you you
followed someone for a year but like a
documentary and the only real outlets
back then it was hbo
you know maybe some sort of film
festival or something for a documentary
maybe it would go to home video but it
was a two hour essentially maybe two and
a half hour presentation and it wasn't
until the years and years later that
people had this sense that you could do
multi-parts
10 hours 12 hours whatever else i mean
that
nobody as you know thought in those
terms back then but i'm a conspiracy
theorist here it felt like the timing of
this lebron had just won another
championship and it felt like let let's
and you know how competitive jordan is
let's remind everybody of why i'm the
greatest of all time and it comes out at
the time that lebron wins a championship
so let me present that storyline to you
commissioner
uh
you know i i don't think
michael is immune uh from
hearing about other potential goats out
there
you know
you know it was never said directly but
i i think there has to be a part of him
that as he's watching the game today and
the way he approached it the way he
approached
you know every minute of every game the
number of minutes he played he had
seasons where he averaged 40 over 40
minutes you know i i remember in those
days you know again because i was
at me entertainment and doing the
television stuff
that
he felt an obligation to play every game
yeah i mean he knew
not just for a television audience but
he knew and every time he played there
were families there were others who had
saved their money potentially scout the
ticket in those days as they called it
to see michael jordan play and i think
he personally felt that it weighed
heavily on him maybe there were even
times he played that maybe doctors
didn't want him to play but as you know
it was a different time but you know i
look at zion williamson this year let's
go back to michael's second year where
he breaks his foot
he wouldn't he wouldn't play in today's
nba
right the celtics series which i think
was the coming out party
for michael jordan
was that series in the garden when he
put up 63 that wouldn't have happened
um and i know that you you
you know we're trying to incentivize and
what do you do to get players to play
more games and
mike would have been held out probably
the whole season i'm going to imagine in
today's nba i i think that's right i
mean and and i'll just say you got to
find the right balance because there's
also
players
former great players who you and i both
know or somewhat hobbled
today
because maybe they played at times they
shouldn't have so you know i i think
your word incentives are the right is
the right one because i think there are
situations today where
even aside from injuries where you know
load management as they call it these
days there are were perfectly healthy
players
somebody at a team can tell you on
november 15
that on january 19th this player will
not be playing in this game because our
program suggests
that would not be good for his health
and i think that it's
more of an art than people acknowledge
sometimes there's a suggestion it's pure
science and we know will reduce injuries
by a player not playing in that game now
of course if you argue if you play fewer
games maybe
decreases the likelihood that you'll get
injured but it's it's the right balance
because
players understand it's a business too
they're
entertainers yes
people who are rooting for that team
want that team
to optimize that player on the floor and
not overdo it but at the same time
these guys are paid enormous amount of
money to play this game and and
it's a little out of skew right now
there's no question and i think it's i i
mentioned it the other day when i was
doing some media about
what it is we need to do working with
the players association to create
greater incentives for guys to play
a full complement of games but but not
push to that point where
as maybe happened in the old days where
guys truly felt they needed to play
through actual injuries and maybe
shorten their careers well what about
minimum games to be eligible for
postseason honors
i think that's a good idea i think
that's something we should look at i
think that would be a way
to incentivize guys um
i i think there's an expectation that if
you are going to be an mvp or
whatever the
whatever that award is even first team
second team third team all nba
sure i agree with you i i i think it's a
good suggestion i think it's something
we're going to be going into collective
bargaining fairly soon
and and my sense is
it's something that in the aggregate
most players would think is a good idea
too i mean the conversation we're having
is not all that different than the one i
have with individual players i mean i
think they're fans of the game they want
to see guys on the floor and in fairness
to the players in many cases it's the
teams these load management programs are
coming from our teams not the players so
it's often a trainer who is saying to a
player and and by the way i've had this
conversation with with michael michael
jordan and you know he thought at the
time that he was more likely to get
injured if he sat out again
like he he he thought like if he got out
of his rhythm that that might lead to an
injury so while he felt that obligation
to the fans and and what was different
to in those days there were games and
every game didn't get the scrutiny got
now but maybe it was a game that
certainly wasn't on national television
less important competitively but he
would start he may they may take him out
he'd start the third quarter but for a
fan who was there
tuning in or in that arena maybe their
only chance to see michael jordan he
made sure that he was on the floor we're
talking to the nba commissioner adam
silver we got uh games coming up tonight
you got the hawks at the cavaliers
pelicans at the clippers
all right this is something i'm sure
that you have not been addressed or have
addressed or been bothered by but it
bothers me
do we just
decide now that you can't carry the
basketball palm the basketball in the
nba like we've moved on that you're
allowed to do that commissioner
interesting you should ask so i i've
i've had this conversation with monty
mccutchen who's the head of officiating
and
one it's a the players um cover so much
ground now they're so skilled it's a
tough call to make first of all i i
think it may be
that
the rule needs to be changed because
the way the rule is now written
is that you can't put your hand
under the ball completely under the ball
or bring it to a pause i think in some
cases
if you really broke it down the player's
hand is actually on the side of the ball
not under the ball
and that crossover happens so quickly
and there's no pause i'm not sure if
technically i don't think palming is the
word in our rule book but i don't think
as you and i are describing it that it's
technically a violation
there's no doubt our officials miss it
sometimes but
i know that
plenty of fans when i'm in the seats
will say to me isn't that prominent
they're going like this now our
officials are looking to
are looking for the pause
and they're looking to see i think you
know clearly if there's that so-called
frozen moment
they should be calling it but but it is
an area of attention for our officiating
i know it's the little things that
bother me commissioner um
what uh would expansion hinge on i saw
where seattle's mayor talked about you
know
sources or uh las vegas is a possibility
what
like what would be the time frame what
would hinge on expanding
there's there's no
clear
sort of
benchmark to get there i i you know part
of it is a i think a sense of
the governors the the owners of the
teams as to their
you know their view of when it makes
sense to to grow the enterprise i mean
there to me there's two core issues one
is the economics of course and that if
you expand the way i think of the league
the 30 teams there are 30 shareholders
and you're really selling equity if you
just let's say we were expanded by an
even number then
the extent you're growing things get
divided one thirty second instead of one
thirty and so then it's the time value
of money if you whatever the values you
get for that expansion team
what's the cost of that equity that that
you're selling and the value of it so
that's one way we look at it
i think the other is the competition on
the floor and what's interesting in this
league is that even where like another
global sports soccer where there's
multiple great leagues around the world
the bundesliga la liga the english
premier league all top-notch leagues in
basketball everyone would acknowledge
there's one league at the top of the
pyramid globally that's the nba yet even
with all the very best players in the
world coming to this league a game
played by tens of millions of kids
around the world
you still don't have the kind of
competitive parity that we would like
you and i both know you could start the
season and you could say there's a large
group of teams that in all likelihood
aren't going to win the championship or
if you look at a vegas board or
something you'd see where the odds are
and if you expand you you're diluting
talent even more so that is a factor we
look at and and and i think it's it's in
the part of the mindset of the existing
teams how that will work having said all
that
i think
enterprises naturally grow over time and
there's no doubt seattle would be a
great market las vegas would be a great
market um there's there's
state-of-the-art arenas in it's you know
in in both those communities and so
we'll look at it it's interestingly it's
it's not
on the front burner for our
league right now and and also we're
gonna go through a new collective
bargaining um negotiation i also think
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
media world right now um all these new
streaming platforms potentially
interested in sports so it's hard to set
the right value i think that's something
we're gonna monitor as well so
nothing will happen in in in the short
or medium term but we'll turn back to it
at some point
great to catch up with you uh good luck
in the postseason and thanks for joining
us as always yeah thank you dan that's
the commissioner adam silver